[Music]
welcome everyone thanks for coming to my
talk can you all hear me
I guess room is not too big so it should
be fine yeah my name is Surya hosel I
work at ethos come on recommender
systems and my talk today is about
actually leveraging recommender systems
to personalize search first for those of
you don't know ethos we are an online
shopping platform or an online shopping
store we sell so clothes fashion so we
love fashion destination for our target
group is mainly people in their 20s or
young customers there are some steps on
this slide about our customers we have
about 40 million customers about 85,000
products so it's close it quite a lot of
products to go through and yeah
some other stuff about orders and visits
to a platform today as I said I want to
go talk about search and personalizing
search so they send a situation that we
have on ASOS and I guess not many other
platforms is that we have a customer
customer has some such has some sort of
intent for example we have let's say a
female customer who's a student at the
budget and the searching for suit shoes
so to get some result we have another
customer of who we might know that they
always buy certain trainers or that the
specific shoes it would searchers search
for shoes and actually get the same
result and then you can imagine another
customer where we also already have some
history and they might get the same
results again so this is obviously not
that year every customer would get the
same thing and because you already know
something about it we could improve
search for personalizing things so this
is also our motivation behind it I guess
like many other companies we have we
have to send a case that search is
unperson alized
and this is something where we for this
data scientists that this is something
that we can do something about so yeah
we said okay we can look in the first
night and search then obviously if you
can say that to some other people in the
business a lot of questions come up
around that like how could you do that
what's what's the risks what's the
possibilities
there's some machine learning techniques
like predictive modeling using concepts
like make six matrix activations and
other bids to actually make that happen
and what we wanted to do and what
motivated the POC here was the only one
hand to look into what our search
improvement levers that we can use how
can we actually implement something
relatively simple where we use our
existing work in this case from
recommendations and just transfer it to
search so kind of not having to reinvent
a wheel but just using existing
capabilities and also just build
something relatively quick to showcase
to other people in a business so that
they can understand well how could this
look like what could be potential risks
what could be potential use cases and
also just yeah just mixtape data science
more tangible for the business in this
case we didn't want to kind of from the
scratch build like a perfect solution
but just initial puc so when we talk
about personalization we mostly think of
it as re-ranking not filtering
necessarily so the case is that we have
always insert some sort of query term
that the customer puts in we want to
retrieve all the documented irrelevant
based on this query term and then we
rank it based on what we know about the
customer so not necessarily filtered
because we still want to allow the
customer to basically find anything that
you want to find and not subject them
too much to a filter bubble but still
hopefully surface the most relevant
results first as with other many other
problems in data science of machine
learning in general there's no one-one
optimal way to do it impersonation and
search there are kind of many trades or
trade offs that we can think about in
the one hand if I just if I have a very
specific search so let's say in our case
research for I know like a blue trainer
from a certain brand the testers named
and most likely they will only like very
few products being returned in that case
there's no point in kind of thinking
about complex personalization models
because the customer can see everything
then we don't need to personalize all so
there's always a question to what degree
do you want to personalize do you want
to infer everything about the customer
just completely rank everything
do you want to balance for some other
use cases of example music customer is
now looking for something else or is
searching for a gift for someone else so
how do we can be balance all these
things well we started about with on
this we thinking about what do we know
about the users I'm already so because
we have a quite a large customer base we
have a lot of information about them
already so basic things like
demographics easy things like gender we
have preferences of the customers
connected perspective before we know
what sort of brands or product types
they like we can look into item
similarities and sectors and a bit more
about that later on so we can prioritize
certain items that are similar to what
the customer has viewed before or
similar to what the customers bought
before or we can look into product and
customer factors which basically encoder
taste profile of the customer and this
was connected focus of our POC and then
there are other aspects that you could
look into like customer segments context
of example what's the certain time of
the year what's the weather what's the
seasonality and also think about how can
be optimized short term versus long term
preferences so for our work we use a
couple of various tools from the one
hand for the sort of data preparation
and getting the user specific data we
worked with spark spark and - then
importing the data into elasticsearch
using for that I use Jenkins just to
automate the job on a daily basis and
some Java code to make that happen and
then for the actual search functionality
and the personalization I used
elasticsearch JavaScript and Microsoft
issue are just kind of this is the
framework we use for a lot of our work
and it's quite easy to setup
elasticsearch in a cluster there under
the M there and that worked quite well
and then we had a quite a simple
front-end on top of that they just used
JavaScript and HTML in terms of the in
terms of the actual personalization
we can look at a couple of different
sectors as I said so one is basically
just you the preferences for that it's
basically it's very easy to get
that is basically just simple count so
we just get things like what are the
most common brands for example at the
bottom most common brand product type
combinations and we can come up with
weight for that if you want to adjust
use simple counts then looking at
recommendation algorithms what can we
leverage from there and I don't want to
go too much into detail of
recommendation algorithms but just some
main concepts behind it so one major
concepts of recommendations is
collaborative filtering where we use
that the collective user interaction
with products based on that Infirmary
products or our products related
basically in this example the two
dresses would have been usually
interacted in the same way with by
various customers and hence our
algorithm has established that they are
somewhat similar and we can use that in
our search later on or we could work
with some technique that's called
content filtering where we actually look
at their actual products and the product
attributes to understand what is a
similar product so in this case the two
shirts of the same color the same
product range may be same price point
similar brands and we can therefore
establish that they're similar and use
this in our search later on so for
example if I have looked at one of these
shirts previously quite a lot in my
session than a looot life and then I
search again for shirts I could bring up
the other shirt because I might be quite
interested in that or might be quite
useful for me and then another main
technique in recommendations is mating
sexual ization so the concept there is
that we have a lot of users we have a
lot of customers but quite often the
data about interaction is quite sparse
because I think on average our users
they shop around six products per year
they interact with some more products of
views or more products but for most
products they don't have any sort of
interaction with that so there so if you
want to infer how they think about other
products we need some additional
information and for that we use matrix
factorization which is a technique very
basically just establish a large matrix
if all the user and items
wherever there is no
in interaction we put in a weight
everything else would stay empty and
then use the competition techniques they
actually come up with a lower
dimensional representation of the of
these matrix matrices so we then Canada
we would then have item factor matrix
and a user sector matrix and basically
if you can multiply them then you would
have like an approximation of the
original matrix and the nice thing about
that is it it in the end comes up with
quite a concise representation of a user
and a product profile so if you think
about it if you would only have like
three dimension for example twice color
and brand in this case then you could
map the user you could establish whether
user lies in this space and also map any
sort of product to the same space and
can come up with a sort of affinity or
closeness between users and products and
these are the main concepts that we made
use of in the personalization of search
the applying that in pipe lock is quite
easy just a couple of lines of code
where we just actually calculate the
factor so this for example would just be
the factors and we can then also use it
to come up with item similarities so in
our case we looked at the output of
matrix activation and use ultimately all
the items vectors to establish how close
are the different items compared to each
other so in this case you can see that
not surprisingly most items from the
same product type are quite close to
each other so for example a lot of
stresses would be quite similar to other
dresses but you also see overlaps to
other product types of example dresses
lapping over tops or with skirts and
that's something that we can make use of
again in in our search personalization
and within within spark it's again just
a couple of lines of code that you can
use we just we just use the results from
the matrix factorization and basically
just say okay we if you set the user
factors equal to the actual item sectors
then instead of recommending products
per user
we can basically just recommend product
to other product and work with that so
this would give us all the sort of
different personalization in elements
that we need how do we how did we
actually implement it in our POC so we
looked at actually comparing the
standard way of searching when we just
went to a standard Search API and
retrieved results based on search term
and then in our personalized version but
what we did was again we would go to the
standard Search API get all the results
but then fit it into elastic search and
use that as a as a tool to be rank the
results for those of you who don't know
elastic search is basically a RESTful
API based search engine which is a which
is based on Apache Lucille and that that
will allows for kind of quite quite
powerful and search techniques you can
do any sort of standard and full text
based church but also include other with
other tools to customize the search
quite a lot innovated that that is
useful for your purpose and it was is
relatively easy to set it up there a
couple of different tutorials on the web
and we just used the Microsoft Azure and
tools to set up a VM install adaptive
search on that on top of that created a
couple of nodes in the elastic search
and you can scale that quite nicely
based on how your data looks like and
how big your data is and for any sort of
data set that you have you basically
create an index and between this index
you can store any sort of any sort of
documents for example if you have
customer than each customer with the
document imaging store all of them on
the server and then just retrieve the
information from elastic search and the
retrieval is just based on some restful
api method so we have some get called
post calls and so on nowadays we
basically just had like free relatively
simple indices the one with our
customers and the customer details of
example things like gender preferences
or the just a customer sector all of
product data with their published
product properties and then signal so
basically previous customer interaction
with products and then the way we went
about personalizing and the search
results was on a one in the first step
just to get actual the custom
information so you would know we usually
know what who the customers so we just
get all the data we have information for
example about the gender about the print
preferences so in this case for example
it would be that the customers most
interested in TOMS shoes or surface
color preferences for direct black
dresses and for example getting just
getting the customer factors and getting
previous customer product interactions
so just for example the last may be free
product to the customers interacted with
and we can then think about what are the
sort of presentation leavers that we
actually want to set so for example do
we just want to update all the items in
the same gender or use them more the
recommendation techniques of similar
items or using actually the sectors and
personalization elasticsearch how does
that work
so basically our two main techniques how
you can implement it one is basically
just boosting it just means that you
look at the items that are retrieved for
example if a lettuce cook for let's say
blue items in this case we get a couple
of things back from the search and we
could then say okay I know the customer
is a male so we just want to upgrade or
boost all the male items and we just
simply be ranking based on that or we
use something a bit more complex like
for example the recommendation sectors
and we just look at get let me just look
at the items look at all the sectors so
basically just very concise and low
dimensional and vectors that we have of
each product we look at the user factors
and then just compute the dot product to
calculate an affinity score and that's
quite a nice technique to basically just
we rank any sort of product listing that
we that we can retrieve from our entire
product catalog and for any sort of
product user combination we can compute
an affinity score and then just we rank
we went the product list based on that
there are a couple of things to think
about when we want to do that first of
all usually from any sort of full-text
search engine you get a sort of relevant
score back for for a bit specific search
term so there's a question to what
extent do you want to example
personalization to overrule this basic
relevant score should you only look into
maybe we ranking the first 200 items or
the first top items whatever it is but
this is something that you can play
around quite nicely with once you've
implemented the basic functionality in
elasticsearch the actual implementation
is done by a function score query and
this is yeah basically just a query
where you can customize the relevance or
control the relevance in the specific
way that you want to control it so for
example in here we have this filter item
and this is basically just boosting
where we say if the if the gender of the
product matches with the gender of the
customer then VA for example applied to
850 and every item where this applies to
would be updated and then the more
complex query for example where we could
use similar items or factors lies within
a script and the script I think can be
in the form of various languages and
there you can quite nicely just specify
exactly the rules that you want to
implement so in our case we said you
want for example just up with anything
that's based or anything that matches my
top you know maybe 10 brand product type
references I want to calculate the
affinity scores based on the user and
item factors and use that as an input
for the overall score or I want to check
if the item is similar based on the sort
of matrix accusation similarity concept
to my last product interactions and this
then results into quite a lot of text
which is which looks a bit more daunting
than it actually is it basically just
gets all the different elements that we
retrieve from the results of our search
so every every
product it's that's delivered back from
the from the search would have liked all
these different fields that we specified
before so for example to name the
product type or the factors and here for
example we just say we have all our user
factors you have other product factors
and we just iterate through them
multiply them so basically just building
a dot product and then that becomes a
part of our overall score and we can
quite nicely we rank them and put a
catalogue based on that and that's
basically yeah all we need for for
computing of a rear-ending our search
product so so this was for example the
default search on the left hand side
where we had a mixed search result so we
always have some mail items and female
items and it of yeah different styles
depending on how the side is designed
and we quite simply used elastic search
to rear ank the items so in this case
for example we would have the taste
vectors considered I think in the case
where these sort of cat shoes and Nike
shoes where we are pushed up quite
nicely so the user was more into kind of
casual shoes similar items have been
considered so I think cats was in a
similar items or the customer I think in
this case it was actually myself was I
use myself I think its main customer
which is always kind of a nice weighted
trial things and I think about similar
shoes before so then the item sorter
algorithm would just pull out a pull up
similar items to what I've interacted
with before and we could also just use
simple things like the gender so in this
case you wouldn't have any sort of mail
results which are female results and
would hopefully be able to generate more
relevant results for the user and I
think they're quite good in time so I
think I can just show a simple demo
based on that
so this was just okay cut into my
details again
I'm added correctly nope and second yeah
just quickly of tea
if this doesn't work maybe yes it would
be helpful thank you
somehow I always get locked out again
okay cool
yeah so basically we just came up with a
very simple front-end that allowed us to
take this to different people about the
business and just show them how what
would be the impact of personalization
in this case I think if you just look
for one of the brands on the left hand
side we just interacted with the
standard Search API where we just yeah
get back some results on the right hand
side this would be personalized based on
sectors so this would be the item user
factors item similarity so surfacing
similar items based on the last product
interactions and simple things like
gender brand or product type and this we
had some simple sliders here where we
could just experiment with different
ratings around it just observe what's
happened when we don't have any
personalization which should hopefully
yes just retrieve the same results and
then I'm looking into whether we have
some maybe similar items that we can
retrieve and we see something in this
case it would be a tween an item that
was similar to the last purchase just
kind of pulling this up using more more
effect more more information about the
user to actually just yeah we rank the
results I'm a bit more surfing in debt
in this case yeah I think one of the
best performance performances was just
dresses for this brand so we just
surfaces up sync these two items were
driven mostly by the product sector so
just the factors that we computed based
on matrix factorization yes exactly so
they would then just be and pulled up to
the top of the search results and that
allowed us to just discuss this with
different people in the business think
about think about it ourselves just kind
of what it what is the effect how does
it work and just work work on it from
there on in terms of next steps and open
questions
so obviously implementing the person's
ation it's just one part of the equation
there's a lot of other things to think
about and one hand like how do you
balance personalization with other
things like for example just showcasing
items showcasing new items
also just kind of the menu creation of
making a site something more visually
appealing
then how where do we want to use
personation actually building funnel how
does it college can disintegrate into
the oval architecture so our
implementation was just a simple
standalone PC and the elasticsearch work
wave worked very well for that but then
the more complex the queries so the more
complex these sort of functions core
parties the slower the query becomes and
that's something that you see quite a
bit when you when you just kind of
experiment with different person is a
presentation levers so there's yeah so
we kind of think at the moment kind of
how can we make this more scalable how
can we make it faster but that's then
the next step and then also obviously
kind of the whole filter bubble problem
to what extent would you want to rewrite
things into the solution to be for
example just we wait the top items or
should we agree with everything yeah so
this is basically just a lot of still
open questions and things that we want
to look into but having the PLC really
helps us just to kind of get things or
get discussions started and just being
able to talking about the opportunities
and to risk and that's about it
yeah we're also recruiting so if you
have any more questions about around a
thousand what we do in data science feel
free just to kind of yeah talk to me
afterwards as well and I think we have
some time for questions right now
yes so this model it's not in production
yet so this was just basically a fusee
for our purposes that we might look into
testing internally but yes definitely
that would be a idea to actually
understand what is the benefit of having
any sort of personalization I think one
of you could look into maybe doing some
offline testing around that so looking
into what are the things that people
search for and then when ultimately went
on to view went on to buy and use that
as an upland testing but the more robust
results usually get them from online
testing actually implementing that to
some of the customers and seeing how
they interact with it whether it's more
useful or not yes historical data to
evaluate oh yeah so yeah so yeah it sort
of matches kind of offline testing just
looking into how would it have performed
if we would have used it in the past but
we've seen that with offline testing it
is it is quite a limited way it has a
lot of limitations in testing so the
results might have necessarily kind of
completely translate into the same
results in online testing
yeah so to the first question yes we
definitely have people sharing accounts
or people buying gift so I looked for
other for their friends or whatever and
this obviously is quite a challenge for
us between recommendation in general so
we're looking into ways of kind of how
can we maybe identify what works for you
what was for someone else but the 34
account sharing it becomes difficult
because you don't know which user is
currently online or which user you're
sharing with so I think for this you
could look into balancing more the long
term versus the short term signal so one
approach could be that we have the long
term information about your preferences
maybe over the last year and then we see
you doing something specific within this
session and just maybe rely on that what
you're kind of currently doing so this
could maybe counterbalance if you're now
looking for something else or if someone
else is using your account and in terms
of the season even though I'm trends yes
it's definitely something that you see
so obviously now everything is kind of
more shifting towards summer wear so
beach wear in the winter we see around
Christmas we also have a lot of
Christmas products a vodka come up more
and this is also kind of something that
you think of when you think of
international models so how would it for
example work for UK versus I don't know
Australia related yeah you could do that
as well we found I think just the the
implementation first was that we have
used something on Microsoft Azure that's
called it's your data factory which is
just a tool to automate data pipelines
and we already had a script from a
previous 12 that used Java to connect
with elasticsearch and it was easy very
easy to just kind of customized it but
in general there's like a lot of
different clients that elasticsearch
works with so you could use pipes from
JavaScript I think Java and C so
whatever works best it was just a bit of
first it was just a case of reusing
something that was already there just
yeah customizing it a bit
have any challenges yes yeah I think
everything every tool comes with its own
challenges so on the one hand it is it
takes some time to kind of get familiar
with it so where the day is quite some
documentation around it but there's a
lot of trial and error that went into
kind of making things work
there's definitely kind of the sort of
scalability concern especially if you
have more complex queries it might get
very slow and then yes I think there's
the question about around maintaining it
so we're running that on a VM on a
virtual machine is your and if we've
been seeing issues with the classes
being down and then you just kind of
have to manually kind of mean we invoke
them yeah so for us it's not a main
concern because it was more kind of just
the PUC but once we kind of want to take
that further into production this is
exactly something that we have to look
into yeah
I'm definitely very important because I
think where we want to get to ultimately
is being able to insert out during the
session actually what you want to do and
kind of fine-tune our models based on
what you doing already from the session
so this will become quite important but
I think also they're like the matrix
factors that we get out of somatic
sensation of quite useful because you
can you could change them or continue
into kind of how could you amend them
based on the product that you have
looked into during your current search
or maybe use the product that you just
interacted with as the sort of basis for
the similar items to retrieve to
retrieve things from search but there it
becomes in probably a bit more
complicated in terms of how you do you
push this kind of sort of real-time
signals back into elasticsearch kind of
worry to sort of loop into maintaining
the signals in there or whether you have
to look into kind of a different stack
to manage the signals in real term and
then unfitted back into the search
that's something that we are
experimenting with right now to see how
we can work with it
like yeah
um yes so this is also something that we
I'm testing right now and you've seen
that it's kind of its work working very
well so because if you said you can in
addition to actually the product item
interaction you can consider features
for the items for example or features
for the customer and we see we've seen
that the relevance improves when you're
using it so we might just think about
yeah
calculating effective replied if M
instead and just using that main signal
while the recommendation system in
general or the search I think it depends
a bit on whatever KPI if you're looking
into so usually if you're looking into
offline testing we you're looking at the
typical KPIs like recall position and so
on for any sort of online proposition we
would look into things like click like
CTR like 60 rates or conversion rate
ultimately the aim is to enable the user
to find things fast or find things
quicker then hopefully we will see
increased conversions more things that
the user find useful and therefore
interact with them or maybe put into the
basket things like that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]